Next up, talking a little bit about 3D environment, the landscapes and the foliage.
In Unreal Engine, we have a very powerful landscape tool and as well a foliage tool
that you can add terrain, trees, shrubs, other types of vegetation to.
Again, touching upon the modes tab that we were talking about before, you can select
these directly from this tab at the top left of your editor.
You'll be able to find that and you can also see the hotkeys for shifting between them.
So we have specific courses on this but you can sculpt the terrain, vary the foliage,
you can scatter foliage.
They're very intuitive tools and there is a lot of documentation on using them as well
if you like but sometimes it can be nice to just jump in and play around with those tools
yourself.
Like I said, they are very intuitive and you can get a lot of really powerful results in
a really short space of time.
We can also just delete and move foliage around if you've accidentally put it in the wrong place.
So many powerful options in landscape and foliage so they're worth checking out if you
need those for your projects.